Hey, what's going on? Is Bill burn
his time for the Thursday afternoon?
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and I
just checking in on you. What's going on?
Whoa, whoa. Jesus. The levels, the levels.
What happened?
You know,
one of these days I'm actually going
to have like a little podcast room.
I mean they have one in the all things,
comedy studios.
I just never get over there.
I never get over there
because I'm a working stiff.
I go to work every day.
I'm in a job in fucking 20 years and I'll
tell you right now, I didn't miss it.
Oh, I did miss getting in the
fucking car bump up, but due do too,
right? I don't think I'll ever
get over. Oh fucking awful.
The drivers are out here.
I just,
their complete lack of sense
of where their fucking car is.
If one more hunt in front of me is going
to make a left and they're just sitting
right in the middle of the lane,
get over to the fucking left so
everyone around you can go around you.
I know you've been the guy
trying to get around the person.
Did you learn nothing? Obviously
you did. Obviously it didn't.
I try, I play like a little game. Like
how long can I go before I lose my shit?
Like I could literally just make a
great youtube show. If I just put a,
I don't know about great,
but it'd be interesting if I just put
a GoPro up on the inside of my fucking
Prius Dashboard and just,
just maybe you just call the show.
How long can he go right
there be like everyday.
Okay. Bill drives from here to
here. Right? I might do this.
Bill drives some here to here,
whatever you'd,
you say the distance and
then you guys can gamble.
It's like fantasy football without
the fucking football and you,
you the AUV 11 over under.
How many times is he going to snap?
Um, or whatnot, you know, already
forget the name of the show,
but whatever it could be.
It could be interesting to me.
I don't know if it's interesting
to Yo, hey, you know,
carbon seen lately that I'm actually,
I like,
is that Volkswagen Gti?
They brought the thing back and every
time I peek in creepily into the fucking
cars as I walked by and see that
they still have to stick shift,
there's not a lot of those left. That's
a great car. Could Bang for the buck.
Right. All Frugal freckles, Eh,
God forbid he buys himself
something flashy. Um,
I swear to God you'd think
that I lived in the depression.
I always hear like my parents are
fucking frugal. Their grandparents. Well,
I think it rubbed off on
them and then it's on to me.
I'll buy my fucking wife anything but I,
I won't buy myself shit.
I just won't do it. I always get Dale,
I'm going to buy it, I'm going to do it.
And I go, oh, what the
fuck am I going to do?
And then I'm going to have it and then
what that 1:00 AM I going to do with it.
Then it's just going to be sitting there.
It's either going to get dust on it or
someone's going to drive into the fucking
side of it. What's the point? You know,
a very wise man once told me, you know
what true wealth is walking into a mall,
being able to buy anything
and then you don't,
and he goes into your walkout and you
have the freedom of that lack of debt.
And I'll tell you, it's fucking
addicting. It really is.
Although recently somebody just gave
me a fucking wireless baker and I was
freaking out about the thing.
I actually synced up my phone to it.
I couldn't believe how great it sounded
and I was going to add it into my gym
course until uh, the lovely Nia heard
how good at sound. She was like,
that should be in the house.
We should both use that. So I,
you know, I got fucked
out of that thing, but um,
so I'm like an asshole. I think it might
have even told the story on Monday.
I was actually texting people, telling
them, you got to get a wireless speaker.
This thing is fucking incredible in every
one of my friends wrote me back. Like,
uh, yeah, I kind of bought one of those
like five years ago and I was like, oh,
you know, just, you know,
case shad. You know,
I just figured it out.
You know what?
I'm actually recording cause my wife still
sleeping and it's her birthday Bateau
doodle doodle, right. So I don't want to
wake her up, which I probably already did.
So, um, um, in this uh,
Homina Homina I'm in this room and I have,
these are all my old drum.
I can't even say DVDs. Mulch.
Most of these are VHS I bought.
I bought like every instructional
fucking video you could the classic,
I got the Tommy Aldridge rock drums
soloing and double bass workout.
I got another one, double bass
drumming. I don't even know who that is.
I don't even play double bass.
Uh,
Kenny aronoffs power workout number
one and two with the workout booklet.
I got the Carter Beauford
one that's a DVD.
I get Steve Gadd up close.
I got the funky drummers who
have the David Garibaldi,
these tower of groove all
Mara Keane let it flow.
The modern drummer festival to year 2000.
This is all just drum geek shit. I
got fucking everybody. Keith Carlock,
Dennis Chambers, the drum Basadur. Yeah.
Okay.
Drummer collective 25th.
Oh. Then I got Steve.
Glad up close on DVD and in session two
copies of that for some fucking reason.
Jesus Christ. Look at all these fucking
things. Modern drama. What year is that?
One, 2008. That's not bad. John
Blackwell. Greg Bissonette. I got,
I got them all. I got 'em off. Dave Weckl.
Yeah.
Victor Wooten and Carter Beauford.
Zoro I got,
I got them all. Got them all. God knows
it didn't help, but you know what?
I bought them off. Oh, I
bought 'em all. Um, by the way.
So recently I said, oh, buddy of
mine. Um, I was like, you know what?
I think the best guitar sound,
my favorite guitar sound I ever
heard on an ACDC album was the,
for those about to rock album.
And he was like,
I never listened to that fucking
thing and blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah. And, uh,
that was the album that came out right
after the back in black album, which sold,
you know, like fucking 90
zillion copies. So they,
there's nowhere to go after that. Right.
There is no fucking way to go after that.
So no matter what you come up with
people who are going to say it's a flop.
But I fucking love that album.
And um,
and it just so happened Dean del Rey from,
um,
oh Jesus,
I just spaced on the name of his
fuck podcast for those about to talk.
No, let there be talk. And it
was one of the AACD Salem's.
Um, he, uh,
he sent me this great article on the
making of the back in black album and I
wrote, I was so crazy to me because
I was old enough when that came out.
Like I remember when
back in black came out,
I was 12 years old and
then dirty deeds came out,
which was actually a bond, Scott,
and he was already dead obviously.
And then they release that
for whatever fucking reason.
Now looking at it,
um,
which is crazy because bond Scott dies
right after the highway to hell album and
ACDC gets Brian Johnson
and it's literally like,
if this guy doesn't make it,
they go right back to playing pubs.
Who knows what the fuck happens?
The band's over and they end
up having one of the, you know,
this basically eight
back in black album sold
more copies than anything probably other
than like Michael Jackson thriller or
Pink Floyd, the wall, not the
wall, the dark side of the
moon. Whatever. Jesus. Bill,
get to the point here.
So you think the last thing you would
fucking do is after you've established a
new fucking singer is then put out some
old shit by the last guy who's now dead.
So the, the fucking new guy has to
reestablish himself all over again. Um,
I never really even thought about that
because I just loved everything that they
did. And I remember, um,
being confused of why back in black,
the back,
the guy on back in black sounded so
different on dirty deeds because there was
no fucking information back then.
There was no internet shit just came out
and you're like, oh, another ACDC, I'm,
and then you'd put it on yet no
fucking idea. Especially at 12.
I didn't know what the fuck was going on.
And then for those about the
rock came out after that.
So this is great article talking about
all of that and how that was Atlantic
records,
they thought ACDC was a flash in the
pan and they thought the back in black
album, I don't know how the fuck
you make an album as great as that,
you don't think that they have
anything else left in the tank.
So they were like going,
well let's strike while the iron is hot
and they fucking put out dirty deeds and
the band didn't want them to. It had
been released, I believe in Australia.
And then also in, uh, in um,
England under a different fucking name.
I forget.
I used to know all this shit when
I was super fucking ACDC nerd. Um,
and also I hadn't talked on a cell phone
for 20 years, so I had a memory. Um,
but then for those about to rock came out
and I remember this fucking kid in gym
class going, look, you, you wish you
shell goes both rock. I was like,
I haven't heard of yet to go fucking
socks. I remember thinking like,
what do you mean? I don't think it
sucks. I liked that album. You know,
I like the first song and I find I never
bought the album because he told me
that it sucked until years
later I found just like,
fuck this man, I'm going
to buy this album. And um,
to this day I still listen to that and
like when I go downstairs, you know,
walked right into my garage with my
fucking gym. Right. Which is so awesome.
That's what I play. That's what
I've been playing lately. And uh,
it's fucking hilarious. Like I
literally, when I go to my gym now,
which is just like back in the day when
I lived in my parents house and I just
would go down to the basement and I would
play either appetite for destruction,
the whole fucking album, I used to
play that whole album lift to it.
And then I would go play drums to
it or whatever album I was into.
I would lift weights to the entire album
and then I would play drums to it or
try to, so I'm in the middle
of doing that yet. Uh,
yesterday it was fucking,
uh, you know, bench and day,
your favorite fucking day,
the only only fucking exercise you really
keep track of what weight you put in
up. And I had a flashback. I
fucking, I was half asleep,
you know, right. All Day.
And I tried to get to workout in before
I go into the writer's room so I don't
become a fucking fat pasty fuck.
And um,
so I had the 40 fives on either side.
Right. I do a set and then I was going,
I thought I'd grab tents,
right to just do one 55 and
I wasn't paying attention.
And I picked it up off the bars. Like,
wow, this feels really fucking heavy.
And I just brought it down to my chest
and I was like, I couldn't lift it back.
I grab 25. So I went up to one 85
which, you know, I mean, when you get,
that's a lot of weight for me.
I mean that's more than what I waste.
So I'm sitting there,
I got it on my chest and knee is asleep
and I'm going Neah Bay and I can't get
it off.
It took me back to the days when I was
living at home with my parents and I'd be
going, mom, mom, and she'd be going,
I'll be down there in a minute.
And I'd be down there like with
fucking like, you know what?
85 one 90 sitting on my fuck pacey chest,
trying to get it off 200 pounds.
It was always like,
I was always trying to get up to that,
but I was just, I'm a middleweight man,
like serious.
Like if I wasn't such a fucking booze bag,
like I probably should wait like
between one 61 65 instead of a buck aid,
but that lasts 15 pounds up telling you
it's nothing but Scotch and pizza. Right.
So I got this shit sitting on my
chest that I'm like, holy fuck.
I know I didn't have the clips on it,
but I didn't want to fucking,
I didn't want to dump it off to one side.
You know when you do that and then you
get fucking whipped around because a,
I was worried was going to
fly into the mirror. Right.
So I ended up having to roll the
thing down like back in the day.
And there's that brutal part where it
gets right on your fucking hip bones and
then you got to do the little up and over
your junk before all the weight rests
on your fucking thighs.
Oh, it's the worst.
I hadn't done it so long and the closer
it gets to your knee caps and then
finally you got to do that
fucking thing where it just,
it just scraped your knee bones and
then boom hits the floor. And uh, yeah,
I did that as a 47 soon
to be 48 year old man.
That was my fucking yesterday morning.
I love the whole in this wall.
Isn't that great?
You know why I like the hole in the wall
and I'm looking at right now is I can
see the copper fucking pipe
that I had put in there.
Finally going to get this fixed, get this
fucking room painted. Then that's it.
Then all I need to do is Redo the
kitchen and then it's a brand new fucking
house. It's the house said it should
have been that it used to be, you know,
then I'll probably put
it on the market and uh,
I'll take it for like a $400,000 loss.
Buy a house. People, it's a great
investment. I'm such a fucking Weirdo.
Even though I'm going to lose money
on this fucking house. I actually,
well I guess, uh, I guess I might
never sell it. I won't write. Um,
what I like about it,
what I did to the house is I actually,
this is going to be weird.
I feel like a sense of responsibility.
When you own a fucking house,
you know that the next person should
get it and they should be like,
you know what and appreciate the lien of
the last guy. He fucking did this right.
He kept it nice.
You know,
you ever seen an old guy with
an old car but he kept it nice,
still get it nice and fucking waxed and
all of that shit. And everybody goes,
oh look at that guy. That guy was
raised fucking right. You know,
that's what I'm hoping the next people
are gonna think. But I know they're not,
they're just gonna come in here and do
fucking blow and fuck hookers and you
have some goddamned kid running around
with a fucking crayon and ruined all his
shit.
Not even appreciate that.
I got the fucking door locks fixed and
there's a little skeleton key in there
and you can lock all the
doors like it's 1923 again,
you know when you're going to have
Charlie Chaplin over for some fucking non
genetically altered fucking horse meat
burgers or whatever the fuck they used to
eat back then. Um, anyways, uh,
I need to get glasses by the
way. I got to do that. Um,
I got to get my physical here so I can,
uh,
I told you what the pilot's
license every two years. I got it.
I don't think I'm going to
pass the eye exam and, um,
I was actually thinking about it like a,
I could probably get away with it.
You know, I could probably
do one more time, get away
with it. And it's like, Bill,
do you really want to be like
1300 feet off the ground?
Getting Away with something?
What are we doing here?
Why don't we try to get a fucking
priorities straight, you know,
and make it fucking happen. Um,
so I'm going to go get some, and
I know I'm going to look
like a fucking sex offender.
So already going to be funny to me.
Um, actually, you know something,
you know who did a joke
like that was a Ari Shaffir.
So I gotta give him credit
even though that's, um,
that might even like lifting a joke that
that's exactly what I would look like.
But then it just made me flash back when
he shaved his head and he was talking
about, hey, he couldn't have his
glasses on cause if he put him on,
he looked like a sex offender.
See that.
And that right there is why I don't like
watching other people's acts because
the shit just rolls around in your head
and all of a sudden it just puts one in
the chamber. Um, anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Did anybody,
anybody listened to the Michael
Rappaport podcasts? I am Rapaport.
I called in to his podcast and
we talked some sports and uh,
you know, he ended up wanting to
put money on game seven. All right.
Bet a steak dinner.
And um,
I took OKC and he took a, the
warriors, I forget what the spread was,
but I just didn't feel
like it was enough points.
I didn't feel comfortable with the bed.
It was like seven or something like that.
I just said, do you know what? Bump it
up to eight, you bump it up to eight,
you give me eight points, I'll take OKC.
And he goes, all right, you know, bet.
And you know what, Bam right
there, Fred fucking eight points.
It's exactly what the spread
was, dude, I fucking called it.
So we didn't work out what a what a what
a push would be like, who would when.
So now we're, uh, we've bet the NBA
finals. I took the Cleveland Cavaliers,
he took a, the Golden
State Warriors. So it's a,
can't even say double or nothing because
nobody wanted the first one. So, um,
I don't know. That's always a great
bet. You know, a steak dinner.
It's not gonna break the bank and
then you get to go out and, uh,
even though it's costing you money,
you get a steak out of it, right?
It's not bad when you say, all
right, let's plow ahead here.
Let's do a little bit of a read some
advertising here for this lovely Thursday
afternoon. Ruby, the receptionist, okay,
this has to be some fucking robot
baseball kid at baseball kid,
the baseball kid,
at baseball's words you won't to do
the baseball kid. We'll pitch to you.
And it was literally like the,
for the only child.
Everybody always said it's for
the kid with no friends. It's no,
it's for the kid with no siblings. Cause
even the kid with no siblings. I mean,
no friends still had, still had a brother
or a sister. It'd be like, Hey, could you,
uh, everybody kind of hates me at
school. Could you, uh, throw the barber?
Is there anything worse than that?
How mean kids are to each other?
It's fucking brutal. But
I'll tell you, you know what?
It ends up producing some great comedians.
You know,
some psychos driven to fucking
take their app to the next level.
I'm going to show him.
I'm going to show,
I'm going to go to the reunion. Ever is
going to be, I'm sorry. We pushed it down.
Nobody gives a fuck. All
right, Ruby, the receptionist,
this podcast is brought
to you by, no, it isn't.
It's not brought to you by ruby
receptionist. You fucking entitled Conch.
Start over at Ruby.
The receptionists,
Ruby the receptionist is a
virtual receptionist service.
That means you forward your existing
business phone number to Ruby's friendly
receptionist in Portland, Oregon.
Who Answer on your behalf?
Portland. Okay. Smart Technology shows.
Uh Oh God.
They all dress like Edith.
Wharton smart technology
shows them details about your
business and your callers
even before picking up the phone so they
sound like they're right in your office.
Plus you can provide detailed call
handling instructions for everyone in your
business as well as
okay.
You're for different types of callers.
Take a message,
send them to voicemail or
put them through to yourself.
Best of all, why is my
stomach rumbling? Best of all,
I just had a couple of waffles. Uh,
best of all, Ruby, the receptionist, uh,
ruby receptionists care about connecting
with your colors and making their day
while you're making
your business look good.
Customers agree as a pre repeatedly
rate ruby service as five star on Yelp.
Can you guys hear that? Yeah,
that I just put the mic up to it.
Customers. There it is. It's crumbling.
I just had fucking two
waffles and some bacon.
Customers agree as they repeatedly, right?
Ruby service has five stars on Yelp.
With Ruby receptionists.
It's like having a model full time
employee for a fraction of the cost.
Plus they are. They're never
sick on vacation or out to lunch.
Get started today and call ruby.com/burr
and get free activation on $95 value.
That's call ruby.com/bar.
You know,
it's another thing too is
she can't fuck them either.
She won't ruin your marriage. You
know, no matter how hot they sound,
they're all the way up in Portland. You
know, and who's going to go up there?
Unless you live in Eugene,
um,
tracker or smart phones,
smart cars, smart homes,
technology has made everything smack.
Losing your stuff is still still
makes smart people feel stupid.
Feel wicked stupid dude.
Um,
track or makes losing things.
A thing of the past tracker is
a coin size device that locates,
misplace keys, wallets,
bags, computers, uh,
Snowden. Anything in seconds, just
pair tracker to your smart phone,
smart phone and attach it to anything and
find its precise location with the tap
of a button. It's that
easy. Lose your phone,
press the button on track and your
phone rings. Even when it's on silent.
Isn't that creepy with over
1.5 million devices tracker?
Has the largest crowd
gps network in the world,
so your last item and show last item shows
up on a map. Even if it's miles away,
never lose anything again with tracker.
Listen listeners to this show,
get a special discount offer
of 30% off your entire order.
Go to the spelled t h e tracker,
t r a C K e r.com and
enter the Promo code bird.
The hardest thing you'll ever
have to do is find their website.
Go to tracker.com right now and enter
the Promo code birth for 30% off your
entire order. Again, the tracker.com
Flash, Barb, promocode, Burt, whatever.
All right, is it not slash bar? No,
the tracker.com Promo Code [inaudible]
that's what it is. All right, and finally,
lastly,
but certainly not leastly.
We don't anyone of these advertisers
to feel left out that anyone is more
important than the others.
His chest at some point someone has to
bring up the rear. Look at it this way,
you're batting cleanup, Boll and branch.
Everybody sounds like a steakhouse,
but it isn't. As you said,
to improve yourself. This is,
there is one simple thing you can do every
day to help you be your best in every
situation. And that's getting a good
night's sleep. Isn't that the truth?
Boll and branch delivers the rest you
need wrapped up in their super comfortable
luxury linens and they do it right there.
First bedding company to be there,
the first bedding company
to be fair trade certified,
which means that your sheets come
from the work of happy hands,
not from sweat shops. You know something.
I wish more companies did this man,
you know,
considering everything I made I'm wearing
was fucking sewn together at three in
the morning.
But God knows who um,
and beginning and beautiful packaging
made entirely from recycled and
sustainable materials.
Look at this company.
They've got their head screwed
on straight. Do you know what?
Everybody's got a weakness. I wonder
what they're doing. I wonder what it is.
It's probably smoking meth.
Um, next please mention that.
I'm going to mention it if you give it
to me. All right, let's get through this.
You can only get their sheets in one
place. That's Boll and branch.com.
Where you know you're paying for quality
and not department store overhead.
You're getting thousand dollars sheets
for just a couple of hundred bucks.
Go online to bolt,
that's B o l l and branch.com like cliff,
like tree branch.
And they'll let you try them.
Risk free for 30 nights.
You can't lay on them during the day,
but 30 nights she got them. If you
don't love them, you can send them back.
You got nothing to lose
and it gets even better.
Go to and branch.com today
for 20% off your entire order
sheets, towels, blankets,
do VA covers everything.
Plus free shipping and all their products
come beautifully packaged in their
signature boxes.
Go to Boland,
branch.com today for 20% off your entire
order and use the Promo Code Burr.
That's Boll and branch.com
Promo Code Burr.
Hey Boll and branch.com Promo Code Burr.
Alright,
mine. The only one who kind of looked
at Ruby, the receptionist. I, you know,
just the way they were that
and now you don't, you know,
for a fraction of the cost, you can
underpay these fucking people. You know,
I like a fucking receptionist.
I mean, you know,
I might be old school, I
might be sexiest, sexiest,
a sexy sexist is what I'm trying to say.
I liked the reception.
The hoary are the better
signs they get the job done.
It's not that better when you walked
in, right. And there was some fucking,
you know, chick walking around
with fucking fuck me pumps on,
you know,
she looks good and all these
goddamn feminists out there
that sit there and they
flip out and they act like every fucking
beautiful woman out there would be a
chemist if it wasn't for men.
Like make you know,
some of them they're putting their
best foot forward. Jesus Christ.
What do you think we
have remote controls for?
Because no one wants to get up
off the couch and God damn it.
If a woman is born beautiful and now she's
got to do is walk around with the Ras,
jacked up and attach jiggling
around a fucking office.
And next thing you know she's got a
beautiful home to go home too, right?
Cause some rich guy goes in there and go,
you know what?
I'd like to stick my billionaire
Dick between those tits. Hey,
what's wrong with that? And then
meanwhile, so fucking, you know,
half a Leprechaun jerk off like me
can come in and I got some to look,
look at while I'm waiting for the fucking
doctor to finally come in and figuring
out what's wrong with my spinal cord.
What is wrong with dad?
What is wrong with debt? You homely
fucking haters of beautiful women.
God bless him. God bless him for just
showing up and looking good. You know,
given you some to rub one out to, you
know, everything serves a purpose in life.
Like right now,
if you some broad and you listening to me,
I'm probably motivate you to go write
some paper maybe in Portland, you know,
we all serve a fucking purpose.
Can't we just let the horse be whores?
You know,
there's a reason the word exists.
All right. And I, you know,
I guess because men are running
shit that sometimes there's,
there's fewer options, but give me a
fucking break. You know what I mean?
It would be great if everything was
like even, you know what I mean?
Everything was just fair and the
best got the fucking job right.
But that's never going to happen because
we're human beings and that includes
those feminists who don't want it equal.
They just want it better for them. Right.
That's why they're only
talking about women.
They're not talking about the poor kids
that's so together. Their bedsheets,
unless they go to boll and branch. Oh,
that little call back to the advertising.
All right, let's just say
it was free, not free.
Let's just say everything
was fucking even,
are you really going to tell me that
they wouldn't still be that chick running
around just fucking blow with people
because she enjoys it. Why can't she just,
you know, why can't she have a good time?
Don't you judging her? Oh, you home.
We hate her. Of a cock. Gobbler Huh?
I don't even want, I'm talking about,
I'm just filling up time here. Oh,
would you look at it at 26 minutes in 26
minutes in and I'm waiting for my lady
to wake up. I've got a couple of
nice gifts. Couple of right there.
Fred's Huh?
I'm a big fan of buying your wife
like something that she wears,
you know, cause the more shit that
you buy her that she wears clothes,
necklace, jewelry, any of that bullshit,
the more that shit that you buy her,
the bigger chance she's
going to be wearing it.
When she's bitching at you about something
and all you do is you just put your
eyebrows up and as she's rare, where you
just point to whatever you bought her,
you know, stops him right
in their tracks. Well what,
say you got some money Arista,
what is that?
And then the first they're looking at
what did I, did I put my arm in something?
No, no, no. Right there on your wrist.
And then they just look down and they
realize what you're doing and they just go
out and then you laugh and it's over.
You laugh and then it's over, right?
And you go over, you do a couple of
Jaeger bombs over at your fucking bar.
And you'd be like, what? When
you're drinking too much.
And then you point to the airings,
what is,
there's something on the side
of my face. Oh yeah, it's great.
And then you get another round telling
you all you assholes who are hiding your
booze in the back of your fucking toilet.
Just ease off on the booze.
Buy Your wife a couple of things
that she's going to be wearing.
And then you can drink
in public like a man.
You know Jesus fucking Christ Jesus.
You know,
you imagine being that big of a
drunk that you're actually like,
cause that's so fucking cliched.
You know it's also brilliant too.
You know the first guy who did it
cause he keeping it nice and chilled,
right?
Taking it up the back.
Oh God. What a fucking, how
unhappy is that God damn life.
Your wife's just sitting there fucking
yammering at you and you're going,
oh my God, this, I don't think I
can get through this. You know,
and she thinks she got some sort of weak
bladder. You just keep going in there,
you know,
taking the little cork out,
taking a swig like a fucking pirate.
Then you got to flush the toilet,
like it dropped another dose.
Oh my God.
I guess if you're an alcoholic
you probably eat better. Right?
You just keep eating veggies all the time.
So no one would get wise to the fact
he had a little bottle back there.
I really don't even know what
I'm talking about right now.
All I know is that the
Pittsburgh Penguins,
the knee breakers, they're
up, uh, two games to none.
What a fucking story that's going to
be if they win. I'm tell you right now,
I don't know what the fucking odds were,
but nobody,
people even in Pittsburgh then even
put money down and if they did,
they just did it because
they love their team.
But nobody at the
beginning of this season,
there's no Pittsburgh penguin
fan that said, you know what,
the penguins are going to make
the fucking Stanley Cup final.
They're gonna make the finals, they're
gonna make the Stanley Cup final and uh,
they're going to go up two games to none.
There's not person that one
parameter, Panini, whatever the fuck.
And that place is called where they stick
the French fries and like fucking your
breakfast and your dinner in
between those buns. Right?
There's nobody standing down there,
right.
With the giant fucking back roll.
You know,
Pittsburgh's big on that man.
People guys sit down at bars and then you
just got like those just softball size
chunk of fucking Lard, you know,
just protect. It's like the,
the kidney airbag,
right?
It's sitting there. Right. And
you know, that's not a set,
it's a fucking trifecta.
Cause once you got those,
then you've got the fucking butt crack.
And that's what you got.
That's what you see when you go into
those fucking places. And you know,
Pittsburgh's not the only
place that goes, hey, you know,
we all like burgers and fries. You
know, we all like a sandwich with fries,
but it isn't an annoying that,
you know,
you got to hold the sandwich in one
hand and then pick up the fries with the
other. Wouldn't it be great if he could
just have them all between the sandwich?
You know what I mean? So you can just
shove it down your fucking throat.
I should dial in another fucking
pizza. You know, calling up Domino's,
some shit. They're not the only
ones who do that. There's a,
there's a bunch of fucking places around
the country that do it and I'm telling
you, whenever you go into those
places, it's, I'm telling you,
you see the kidney airbags,
those giant fucking Ham
hocks just hanging. I mean
literally like, I swear to God,
people in Pittsburgh,
I'm telling you like 40% of them,
you could literally take an aluminum
bat and just fucking whack them in the
right net back fat and it would take them
like probably a good 30 seconds before
they turned around you. They felt it in
eight seconds, but they got to get all,
they got to get the momentum to turn
that torso around and all you gotta do is
just stay outside of their meat hooks.
But it's Kinda, I'm telling you,
if anybody from Pittsburgh gets their
hands on you, it's fucking over.
They're going to pull you into that
mass and you're just going to be
claustrophobic like word just yet.
You're going to,
they're going to drown you and they're
fucking man tits. I'm telling you,
the Ami tourists die a
year just accidentally.
They go to Pittsburgh for a fucking pirate
game when the most beautiful stadiums
ever,
right?
One of those fucking ham hock Pittsburgh
fatties gets a little too drunk.
They lose their fucking equilibrium
and they just fall. You know,
you ever see like when they go to detonate
a building, it doesn't fall right?
Or some jerk off goes to cut down a
tree in and lands on his own house.
That's what happens except the house
as a tourist in the trees of fatty from
Pittsburgh. All right. I don't what
I'm saying. All right. That's it.
That's the podcast. Uh, just checking in
on you, right? There's some music. Uh,
enjoy this.
I don't know what the fuck is going to be.
I don't handle this aspect of it.
And then we then you can
listen to the last half hour,
be some podcasts from a year ago and
buy from the same Douche that you're
listening to now. You have been
listening to the Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast just before Friday.
I hope y'all have a wonderful weekend.
You cunts and um,
I hope San Jose once,
not the whole series. I just,
I just need seven games.
This is nothing against Pittsburgh.
I was just breaking your balls.
It's just that this is when like the
panic, my sports panic starts settling in.
Like, Oh my God, the hockey
season's over and bas over.
It's just baseball, baseball, baseball.
The dog days of fucking baseball and
the red sox are in first place too.
I love to get into it. Oh
by the way, month of May,
the cigar count all freckles.
I only had one,
only had one last three months and I
said I'd have two a month this year.
I had two in January,
two in February,
two and a half because one wasn't lit
right, but I don't count that one.
Fuck that too. To had one in March, one
in April, one in May, so that's one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven.
I like that. That's not bad.
Now we're not going to discuss my drinking
though because I'll tell you it's off
the fucking
see you.
[inaudible]
castle.
Hey,
Monday morning podcast on a
Tuesday at 1120 in the morning,
east coast time. Like a,
there was let me slipping,
you know? No, it looks cute.
Actually. I do have excuse.
It was my girlfriend's
birthday yesterday, so, uh,
it's been a great boyfriend
paying attention to her
and someone had to suffer.
You know what I mean?
It's like a threesome.
Someone always feel left out man,
or how much you try to pay attention.
My kid and I never had a threesome before.
I couldn't get one once. I think twice.
The first time I didn't
realize that it was going down.
I was so young and stupid. I was actually
sitting there and I was thinking,
why won't her roommate
leave? You know, the fuck.
And it wasn't until like literally seven
years later I went, oh, wait a minute.
She wasn't leaving because fuck.
And then the other time,
uh,
it was right there on the table and a
one girl was absolutely gorgeous and the
other one, uh, was not gorgeous.
Let's put it that way,
was so not gorgeous that she
eclipse the beauty of the other one,
you know, so, so they, you'd go, hey,
you learn something about me
right off the damn bat. Okay,
well this is what we're going
to do this week on the podcast.
If you guys are new to this
shit, you know, my page. Um,
I didn't want to use every God damn week
and people ask me questions and I tried
to answer them. And other
than that, I babble.
I give you information
about my life and uh,
and that's it. I'm fucking out of it
or right. I drank last night. Okay.
I was celebrating and actually went to
this gut them in restaurant in New York
and went to Bible.
And I'm a big fan of Mario Batali,
but I like Uber better.
Baba was just too,
it was too, uh, uh,
my palate was not sophisticated enough.
All right,
I'll take the blame chooses Christ.
It was like regular dishes
was shit you've never read.
I had beef cheek, Ravioli. Yeah.
Once you fucking take that in for a
minute. All right. And they had, you know,
they had like pheasants
face fucking Lasagna.
It was always like half of what you
had heard of. But a goose liver,
a fucking souffle.
So I dunno,
it was good.
But a Lupa is the shift.
That's the one that I liked that's
got like a fucking, you know,
regular animal's body parts that you
eat mixed in with fucking a Rigatoni.
Oh, what the fuck are you going
to do? You know, if you try shit,
you know, she wanted to go
there. I fucking took her there.
And that's what happened
to cupcakes for breakfast.
What do think about that?
It was sitting there left over
from the party and I said,
that's a great way to start my day.
Let me get myself 9,000
calories of straight sugar.
It was unreal. It was like I did
an eight ball. That's where, eight,
the two cupcakes for 20 minutes.
I was just sitting there thinking,
how fucking great I wasn't.
I'm fucking awesome.
I could do anything.
20 minutes later when the sugar
started wearing off, oh my God.
I started pulling the drapes closed
laying in here like,
I dunno,
I dunno.
Don't ever start your day with
fucking two, two cupcakes.
FTE had a beef cheek.
Fucking Ravioli. Beef cheek. I was like,
cheek like the ass. You being cute.
They're like, no, they actually know what,
I didn't have the fucking balls
to ask him. I didn't want to know.
I was eating somebodies face
meeting. A Yak face. Yeah.
Let me get the Yak taint a rag.
Rag Goon.
All right, let's continue with the, uh,
the continuing story of American
Airlines. If you listened to my, uh,
my podcast last week, uh, these cheap
ass motherfuckers at American Airlines,
uh, you know, the alligator arm,
the fucking food up in first class,
you know what I mean? There are 20
people in first class and they made five.
What's the next thing you know?
I was eating a bowl of total
over Nebraska. Actually, no,
that's not what happened.
Just to give you the quick synopsis, I
said, Fuck you and your honeycomb cereal.
This is first class and I don't get a
Goddamn Mama. I don't want anything.
I said all of that with a
little less anger and no curses.
So a few seconds later the guy came back.
All of a sudden he magically,
he has an Omelet and I'm like,
where did you get that?
And he informed me that the pilots
said he already ate so I could have his
omelet. And I was like, I don't want
his fucking Omelet. I want my omelet.
All right, I don't want
to starve pilot. You know,
passing out up there, seeing bogeys
Lena poured on the Goddamn Yoke,
whatever you call it.
All right.
So I sent them a letter and this is
the letter that they sent back to me.
And I swear to God,
you know,
back in the day if something like this
ever happened and you actually wrote a
letter, at the very least, they give
you a free airline ticket. And I'm,
when I say back in the day,
I mean like 2005, 2006.
Now they don't give a shit.
They just keep apologizing profusely.
This is the dumb ass letter
they sent back to me.
I'm only going to read you part of it
because they just keep saying the same
thing over and over again.
Okay. I think I got the hiccups.
I think I have sugar hiccups
from stuffing down to cupcakes.
Hang on a second. This
room service. Hello? Yeah,
I'm going to check out
about like 15 minutes. Okay.
Thank you Jesus. They didn't
say anything. She said hello?
I said, yeah, I'm going
to check out 15 minutes.
At which point she could have said
okay or overlay, you know. But no,
she just closes the door. All
right. Okay. Here's the fucking,
uh, what have we got here?
This is okay. This is,
this is the letter that American
Airlines sent me. Okay, dear Mr Burr,
thank you for contacting
American Airlines.
It's our privilege to respond to
your message. Okay. First of all,
right there. They already
pissed me off. Okay. Don't,
don't start with off with
your fucking stock line.
Okay.
Like your Jackie Gleason, you know,
thank you for writing as in a way we go,
you know, a little Shevon
off the buffalo. Uh, okay.
I'm very sorry to hear of
your disappointment with
us and regret that you did
not receive your preferred Andre when
you traveled with us in the first class
cabin, uh, cl solar stasis.
Because we want your travel experience
or improving premium cabins to be truly
something special.
We do our best to cater our
entree selections so that
we can serve each customer
the entree they prefer. This is the
part which is just complete bullshit.
Okay. They want to make sure that they
serve the entree that I prefer. You know,
and yeah, you can do that. Bringing
up fucking eggs on the flight.
This is what they right to do.
So we determined which entrees
are selected most often.
It's often and provision accordingly.
That's fucking bullshit.
They watched Jurassic Park when Jeff
Goldbloom did his little rant about chaos
theory.
Okay.
You think cause you take 10 flights or
a hundred flights and you figure it out.
Oh, you know, seven people want the Omelet
and and you know, nine people want
something else. That's such bullshit.
First of all,
nobody wants to fucking cereal.
No one wants cereal at first class.
Okay,
you fucking dropped $1,500 or whatever
the hell is 800 $1,500 on tickets.
You want something of substance of
stick a pitch in about this. Oh,
I know it was in the end of it.
I ended up flying fucking a middle seat.
The fucking Dallas and all
I got was $150 voucher.
She'll pay for one third. They
didn't give me anything. Mr Barrow,
we are not unmindful of the
inconvenience of you. Well,
how the fuck would you be on mindful?
I wrote you a God goddamn letter.
As hard as we are trying to deliver on
respecting your time by operating our
flight is scheduled. It just
wasn't possible this time. Again,
we apologize for the disruption of your
travel plans. We're not giving you shit.
Please sly with us again soon.
We'll do our best to get you
to your destination as plant.
Really, you're going to do your
best. That's what you can give me.
American Airlines. Well, Gee,
you know, we're going to try.
That's a comforting attitude to have when
they're going to be flying it fucking
36,000 feet off the goddamn ground.
Oh, do I sound like a camp this week?
So that's basically it.
That's, that's the, uh,
the next level that they've taken it
to where it used to be like, okay,
we fuck you over. And the stewardess
gives you a hand job. You know,
that was 1975. Then in
the 80s, it was, you know,
we'll give you a free ticket and a skinny
Michael J. Fox tie, but those things,
you know, and you had the little
spiked out mullet. And uh,
that lasted for a good 20 years.
And uh,
somewhere in the last four
or five years it became a,
we're going to fuck you over red back.
Go Fuck Yourself. We think about that.
Go Fuck Yourself.
It was
299 other people on the plane
that didn't fit in complaint.
What are you gonna do?
Take the train.
It's going to take him nine days to get
to New York. Go Fuck Yourself. You know,
you're coming back. It's
just eggs. Get over yourself.
You know what? They got me over.
God Damn barrel sounds a bit just,
what am I gonna do? Flight
APA. You know Nina fucking,
yeah,
I don't know what in a God damn chicken,
actually I think Ata recently
went out of business.
You have a flying an airline and then
you know, you're like, Eh, you know,
it was kinda weird flight. You
know, there was a crack in the uh,
inner window actually that happened to
be on Ata. One of the windows, you know,
they got like, they got the,
the double pane of glass,
they got the one on the outside,
the outside of the plane and then
they have the one on the inside,
the extra level one.
And that one was cracked.
And I believe it was a little bit of
water in there. And I said to the, uh,
to the stewardess, I was like, a woman.
There's a fucking crack of
the goddamn window over here.
I'm afraid I'm going to get sucked out
once we get above 6,000 feet. She said,
it's like I felt kind of like class.
Yeah.
You know, so I didn't feel bad
when they went out of business.
Now I kind of felt bad because now
there's no, there's no other option.
I guess that's my other option.
You do.
I sit there and I take it on American
Airlines and they go, go fuck yourself.
All right,
we're going to give you a bran muffin.
I hope you brought some water
or I fly another airline window.
Inner window was cracked and
no one thinks it's a concern.
Tanner winters crack. Well, that's, that's
why they got two of them. All right,
this, this, this podcast
is just a cluster. Fuck.
Let's get to some podcast
questions that I didn't even,
I didn't even have the time to
fucking look at this week. Actually.
That's not true.
I went to look at them and somebody,
I don't know what's going
on with my myspace page.
I don't know if anybody else
has had this problem, but, uh,
I have not been able to really add
anybody for about a year. You know,
every couple of days they'll get
about 45 requests, I'll accept them.
And then a day later I have
47 people taken off my page.
And it's like, really? We're
all those people spammers.
I don't know what's going on. So, uh, I'm
having somebody looking at my account.
The only question I can remember,
I can't even remember us.
It was something about
fucking, uh, you know,
what movies do I find scary?
Um, well, you know what,
if you turned my flight on
American Airlines into a movie,
I would've found that fucking scary.
Um, what movies do I find scary?
Anything that involves a crazy woman?
Um,
I think the scariest movies,
one of my first got cable in the early
eighties when I had a tight jeans and a
pony high tops that just met the bottom
of my jeans and no one complained
because somehow you could get
away with that back then. Um,
I remember the first Friday, the 13th
when Jason came up out of the lake,
that scared the shit out of me. And there
was another one. His, here's one for you.
Okay.
I got a podcast question for you guys.
There was a movie I saw late night cable
and I can't remember what the fuck it
was,
but it's somehow there was
somebody skating across the
pond in slow motion with
an ax.
And I believe for some reason the,
uh, the monster I'm
picturing is, is from that.
I know this isn't it,
but the picture of my mind is what does
that monster book where the wild things
are? You remember what those
monsters look like? In my memory,
that's what the monster look like.
Skating across the fucking lake. Uh,
and I know it isn't that, but I know
somebody. What are you, what am I,
14 listeners out there has to be
a fucking horror, horror film. Uh,
whatever the four, what do
you call someone's really
into horror films. Like Geek.
Yeah, exactly. A horror film.
Fucking deek. There was that one.
And uh,
there was another one I was just
thinking of and I just sat up and I can't
remember it.
I'm getting fucking age.
I literally just moved my brain a
little bit. The thought just went away.
Wait a second. What the fuck was I
just thinking? Let me lay back down.
Let me see it. It'll come back to
me. Okay. I was talking about, God,
we got to go back in time. You
know, I was talking. Okay. The lake,
while things are,
see this side of my brain works,
it works linear. Once I go past
the moment, I can't go back.
It's like a fucking traffic jam.
What the fuck was I trying to think of?
Ah, Shit. I don't know. Oh,
I got it. Bam. There we go.
Um,
dark night of the scarecrow.
I like the old horror movies.
Okay. This is what, you know what?
I don't like about new horror movies bid.
They would that CGI shit.
They,
they can do so much insane stuff with
computers that they forgot how to build
suspense. The old ones they
used, they used to build it up.
They used to build up the moment where
the monster was going to jump out at you
because they had to because it was
just a guy in a rubber fucking soup,
you know what I mean? But now
that they can, they can, you know,
they can make it look like
Godzilla is stepping on New York.
They forgot how to build to Spence.
That's what I don't like about fucking
horror movies now. And that's a,
I think Japanese,
I don't know everybody over in seems
to know how to fucking do that,
but nobody over here. It does even
like the like, like thrillers,
whatever the fuck, whatever a goddamn
thriller it's might take that,
that movie a perfect storm.
They had that goddamn big wave.
That's all they showed in the trailer.
So everybody goes out to run out and see
it and then they don't develop any of
the goddamn characters to the point that
I don't give a fuck about anybody in
the movie. So by the,
by the end of the movie,
I'm actually praying for the wave.
I can't wait for them to kill George
Clooney and Mark Walberg and all those
other guys because I don't give a fuck
about their characters because if they
haven't done anything
to make me give a fuck,
they just had a couple people speak in
Boston accent and you stick them on a
tugboat and I'm supposed to give a shit.
They're going to die trying
to get lots of stuff.
I'm just in a bad mood.
I'm going to bad fucking mode today
and let you know what it is is to God.
And don't ever start your day
with two fucking cupcakes.
It seems like such a great, you know,
such a great idea. You know, like, Oh,
I'm eight years old.
This is what you'd want to do,
but your parents never let you, you
know? And now I'm 39 and 51 weeks.
Finally the dream that I
thought was going to happen,
you know? Oh, it did happen and it
doesn't play out right. Oh my God.
How did I forget this shit?
I know why I forgot it because I have
fucking two cupcakes with the sugar.
My brain. I actually got a crazy
week. How crazy was it bill?
Um, I flew into New York on Wednesday.
I did opie and Anthony Opening,
Anthony Opie and Anthony
show Thursday morning.
Then I did my show at Carolines
in New York Thursday night.
I got up Friday morning, got
on a plane, flew back to la.
I did the guys choice awards on Spike TV,
met all these famous people. They
were all cool. I had a great time.
I met Nikki Sixx.
I was way more thrilled and the after
party was at the fucking playboy mansion
and I know what you're thinking.
Oh my God, playboy fucking mansion.
That must have been unbelievable.
I quickly realized when I got there,
there's two kinds of parties
at the playboy mansion.
There's the your famous and you can
come by Wednesday afternoon and actually
meet the broads that are in the magazine.
And then there's the one that I
went to where it's like, yeah,
why don't you guys all just stand on my,
in my backyard?
I literally thought I was going
to show up to the mansion, right.
It was going to be like me and eight
other people and just, you know,
for playboy bunnies eats just rubbing
on my chest. Hey, you're a big boy.
I heard you're a comedian now.
They just had, they had the,
it was definitely the beat
team, a playboy bunny, you know,
they had a little bunny
suits on and the rabbit ears,
but let me tell you
something. And they were, uh,
they were grade a hooter girls and he
could tell there was three of them who
were clearly being paid
to frolic in the pool.
And any girl with bunny ears had like
nine guys around her was a fucking sausage
fest. And this is the funny
thing, nobody was hitting on them.
They was standing there with
their fucking cameras out,
taking pictures like,
uh,
like they were at Disneyland and they
ran into Donald Duck or something.
It was pathetic. And uh, you know,
Hugh Hefner was roped off with his three
fucking girlfriends, 83 years old, man.
Got, I think it was the shit that
was the only thing I wanted to do.
I just want to go in there and shake his
hand and then immediately stick my hand
in bleach to get the unbelievable smell
of 50 years of pussy off of my hand and
then fly back. But he
was busy. I understand.
He had to meet a famous fucking people.
So, uh, but still, it's still a shit.
And then I flew back the next day,
six in the fucking morning.
I landed in New York at about four 30.
I got my bag,
I went over to Caroline's and I
did three fucking shows, you know,
and then I went out drinking afterwards.
And that's the kind of thing that leads
you to be in a country mood on a Tuesday
morning. You know, I did all of that
and then I ate two cupcakes. All right,
so don't even question my
fucking move. All right. So, um,
so there you go. That was my week.
Went to a party at the playboy mansion.
I could stand up on my first award show.
When is it going to be at you ask why.
I'll tell you it's going
to be on not June 22nd. Um,
and I had a great time doing the set,
even though
most of the crowd was a pay crowd,
you know, good looking people,
hot chicks texting each other and I god,
what kind of,
when this is going to be our bar.
And I said [inaudible] I want
to blow Jeremy Pippin. Um,
it's going to be on June 22nd.
And this week coming up this week,
I'm going to be at a good
night's comedy club in Raleigh,
North Carolina.
You can go to [inaudible] dot com and
get all the fucking information. And uh,
later on this month, I'm going to be
the punchline in Atlanta, Atlanta,
the brothers call it. And, uh,
I think that date is June 19th or
something like that. I don't fucking know.
I can't get on this hotel internet and I
have to check out in 19 fucking minutes.
So I got to go apologize for the
podcast being a day late and a,
forgive my continuous on this podcast.
I'm going to blame it on the
sugar from the two cupcakes.
What a fucking half a fag, Huh?
Starts the day with two cupcakes.
So they call me Billy to cupcakes.
Billy cupcake. All right,
you guys have a good week.
Please keep the podcast questions common.
Sorry about this week, man. I had some,
I don't know what's going
on with my fucking page or
please keep them coming and,
uh,
let people know about my podcast and
thanks to everybody came out to my shows a
night in Philadelphia, Chicago,
and a in New York City.
All right, you guys all have a good
week. I'll talk to you later. Bye.
So
[inaudible].